la población p dt de bacterias en una
placa de petri satisface la ecuación
diferencial logística de la tasa de
cambio de la población con respecto al
tiempo igual a dos veces la población
por la diferencia de 6 menos la
población dividida entre 8 mil en donde
te está medida en horas y la población
inicial es de 700 bacterias cuál es la
capacidad de carga de la población y
cuál es el tamaño de la población cuando
ésta crece más rápido ok para poder
contestar estas preguntas recuerden que
si en cualquier punto se sienten
inspirados pause en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo ustedes primero vamos a ver
recordemos que queremos decir cuando
hablamos de la ecuación diferencial
logística y la capacidad de carga miren
una ecuación diferencial logística es
cuando tenemos la tasa de cambio que
generalmente se refiere a una población
entonces la tasa de cambio de nuestra
población con respecto al tiempo es
proporcional
de la población y la diferencia entre lo
que conocemos como la capacidad de carga
y la población este es un modelo que
vemos mucho especialmente porque es muy
útil para estudiar cosas como las
poblaciones por ejemplo cuando una
población es pequeña el ambiente
generalmente no lo limita por lo tanto
suponiendo que tenemos una población que
empieza desde un valor diferente de 0
esto crece y esto no se hace muy pequeño
así que la población tendrá una tasa de
cambio que incrementa voy a dibujar una
pequeña gráfica por aquí para enseñarles
la solución típica de una ecuación
diferencial logística aquí tenemos la
población y este es el tiempo entonces
cuando nuestra población es pequeña
supongamos que empieza en un valor
diferente de 0 porque si fuera 0 qué
pasaría en ese caso nuestra tasa de
cambio sería 0 y la población nunca
crecería así que tiene sentido si no
tenemos conejos en nuestra isla
nunca habrá conejos en nuestra isla pero
si tenemos algunos conejos inicialmente
la tasa de cambio de la población
seguirá creciendo conforme esto acelera
pero en algún punto el medio ambiente
limitará el número de conejos o en este
caso de bacterias que pueden crecer en
nuestro ambiente porque una vez que la
población se acerca a esto se aproxima a
cero provocando que nuestra tasa de
cambio sea más y más pequeña así que
podemos imaginar que en el caso límite
conforme p se aproxima a infinito la
tasa de cambio se aproxima a cero así
que una forma de verlo es que nuestra
población será una asín total que tiende
hacia la capacidad de carga ésta
es nuestra capacidad de carga hay un par
de formas en las que podemos contestar
esta pregunta una exponer la ecuación
diferencial logística de esta manera y
así podremos reconocer la capacidad de
carga y la otra es pensar en qué pasa
cuando te se aproxima a infinito
conforme te sea
próxima a infinito esto se aproxima a 0
por lo que podemos usar la ecuación
diferencial logística para saber en qué
valores de p esto es igual a 0 o se
aproxima a 0 entonces vamos a resolverlo
de las dos formas voy a escribirlo
primero así aquí tenemos 6 - p entre
yo quiero que lo escribamos de la forma
en la que tenemos un número menos p
miren si multiplicamos esto por 8 mil y
después dividimos todo entre 8 mil no
estaríamos cambiando el valor de la
expresión así que vamos a hacerlo si
dividimos esto entre 8 mil tenemos que
dp entre dt es igual a 2 p entre 8000
que es p entre 4000 y ahora vamos a
multiplicar esta expresión por 8000
entonces 6 por 8 mil 348 mil menos p
entre 8000 por 8000 nos queda p listo ya
escribimos esto de una forma más clásica
y podemos ver que en este caso la
capacidad de carga es de 48.000 podemos
decir que es de 48 mil bacterias
entonces esto es igual a 48 mil otra
forma en la que podemos verlo es que
bueno la capacidad de carga es lo que
ocurre cuando te se aproxima a infinito
entonces si t se aproxima a infinito
esto de aquí se aproxima a 0 y podemos
ver que la tasa de cambio se aproxima a
cero entonces cuando eso pasa a que se
aproxima p bueno simplemente podemos
resolver esto 6 - p entre 8000 y aquí
tenemos dos situaciones tenemos dos
veces para las cuales la derivada es
igual a cero el primer caso es cuando la
población es cero y él
acaso es cuando esto es igual a cero
vamos a hacer si decimos que 6 p entre
8000 es igual a 0 o bien si decimos que
p entre 8000 es igual a 6 si
multiplicamos ambos lados por 8000 p es
igual a 48.000 y eso es exactamente lo
que tenemos aquí ahora respondamos la
segunda parte cuál es el tamaño de la
población cuando ésta crece más rápido
bueno intuitivamente podemos ver que
cuando la tasa de cambio acelera la tasa
de cambio crece y crece pero conforme
nos aproximamos a la capacidad de carga
la tasa de cambio empieza a desacelerar
así que la tasa de cambio máxima es
cuando la tasa acelera más rápido eso es
lo que ocurre justo aquí pero como lo
sabemos exactamente bueno si regresamos
a la ecuación diferencial logística
podemos ver que la tasa de cambio es una
función la podemos ver como una función
de la población y esta es una expresión
cuadrática
una expresión cuadrática cóncava hacia
abajo que se ve así la voy a graficar si
gráfica mos la tasa de cambio de dp de t
en función de la población cuando la
población es pequeña
supongamos 700 que es con lo que estamos
empezando pero en términos generales si
la población es pequeña la tasa es
pequeña y va incrementando hasta que en
algún punto la tasa de cambio empieza a
decrecer y se aproxima a 0 se aproxima a
0 conforme la población se aproxima a la
capacidad de carga por ejemplo aquí
tenemos la capacidad de carga así que
una forma de pensarlo es que este es el
punto máximo pero como sabemos cuál es
el punto máximo que tenemos aquí para
eso hay un par de formas en las que
podemos saberlo podemos hacer uso del
cálculo o incluso del álgebra tenemos
muchas herramientas para identificar
este punto máximo que en realidad es
como un vértice de esta parábola cóncava
hacia abajo entonces encontremos el
vértice
observen que simplemente se encuentra a
la mitad entre los dos ejes de esta
expresión cuadrática así que necesitamos
hallar los valores de p en donde p sea
igual a 0 pues el vértice se encuentra
justo a la mitad de ellos así que
podemos decir que cuando la población es
0 nuestra tasa de cambio es 0 y cuando
la población es a que ya sabemos que es
48.000 la tasa de cambio nuevamente es 0
por lo tanto como la tasa de cambio
máxima se encuentra justo a la mitad de
esos dos puntos es 24.000 es una
población de 24.000 entonces podemos
decir que esta función escuadra tica y
como esta función cuadrática es una
función de p en algún momento cuando
llegamos a ese punto máximo que ocurre
entre p igual a 0 y p
48.000 podemos decir que la población es
de 24.000 bacterias y bueno al principio
este problema parecía ser muy
intimidante la ecuación diferencial
logística
puedo resolverla y analizarla pero la
clave es que hay que reconocer una
ecuación diferencial logística saber de
qué se trata y después tal vez pensar en
términos de nuestra tasa de cambio como
una función de la población y recuerden
la capacidad de carga es lo que ocurre
cuando t se aproxima a infinito y
conforme t se aproxima a infinito la
tasa de cambio se aproxima a cero
entonces si esto se aproxima a cero a
que se aproximará nuestra población
hemos terminado nos vemos en otro vídeo